THE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT IS
MISSING.
AND SO ARE HIS VOTERS.
AND THAT IS THE ANGLE.
IF CLINTON GOT THAT UPSET
DISCUSSING LEWINSKY, IMAGINE
"THE TODAY SHOW" HAD ASKED ABOUT
THE WOMEN WHO TOLD HIM NO.
JOINING US NOW ARE KATHLEEN
WILLEY AND JUANITA BROADDRICK,
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "YOU
BETTER PUT SOME ICE ON THAT: HOW
I SURVIVED BEING RAPED BY
BILL CLINTON."
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT YOU ALL
DAY, AND ALSO, PAULA.
JUANITA, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU.
BILL CLINTON DID APPROACH YOU,
DID HE NOT, IN 1992, TO
APOLOGIZE?
>> YEAH.
YES.
HE DID.
IT WAS IN 1991.
I WAS IN LITTLE ROCK AT A
NURSING HOME SEMINAR AND SOMEONE
COMES TO THE DOOR AND SAYS, I
WANTED IN THE HALLWAY.
I GO OUT AND THE MAN POINTS DOWN
AROUND THE CORNER BY THE
ELEVATOR.
AND SO I GO DOWN THERE.
AS I ROUND THE CORNER, THERE
STANDS BILL CLINTON WITH TWO OF
HIS ARKANSAS STATE POLICE
GUARDS.
AND HE RUSHES OVER TO ME AND HE
STARTS THIS PROFUSE APOLOGY AND
SAYING, I'M SO SORRY FOR WHAT I
DID, I AM A CHANGED MAN.
I'M JUST NOT THE MAN I USED TO
BE.
EVEN SAID, I'M A FAMILY MAN NOW.
AND I JUST LOOKED AT HIM, LAURA,
AND I -- I WAS JUST
FLABBERGASTED.
I SAID, YOU GO TO HELL.
I WALKED OFF.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE IT.
AND THE NURSES WHO WERE WITH ME
FOLLOWED ME OUT.
AND THEY CAME OVER TO ME AND
THEY SAID, WHAT DID HE WANT?
AND I TOLD THEM.
AND THEN I BEGAN TO FEEL A
LITTLE BAD THAT I HAD SAID THAT,
I KEPT THINKING, WELL, MAYBE HE
REALLY MEANT THAT, MAYBE HE
REALLY WAS APOLOGIZING.
>> Laura: THEN WHAT HAPPENED?
THEN YOU REALIZED...
FAST-FORWARD, HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND YOU WERE PERHAPS
GOING TO BE AN OBSTACLE FOR THAT
GOING TO BE AN OBSTACLE FOR THA
THAT?
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S EXACTLY IT -- A WEAK
LEADER AFTER HE APOLOGIZED,
HE RESPONDED HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: A WEEK LATER
QUESTION MIKE THAT'S REALLY
SUBTLE.
KATHLEEN WILEY, YOU WATCH THAT
INTERVIEW.
I'VE GOT TO SAY, I'M ALWAYS DONE
THAT.
WHY AM I STUNNED?
HE HAS NOT LEARNED ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS EXPERIENCE.
HE'S ACTUALLY A SMART GUY.
I'M ALMOST SPEECHLESS.
YOUR REACTION?
>> I'M SPEECHLESS TOO.
I WAS OUTRAGED.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE THE WORDS
THAT WERE COMING OUT OF HIS
MOUTH.
HE WAS SO ARROGANT AND POMPOUS
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING.
I THINK HE ACTUALLY DOES BELIEVE
THAT HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
AND JUST A BLANKET APOLOGY.
HE HAS APOLOGIZE TO PEOPLE THAT
HE WORKED WITH.
AND THE PEOPLE HE DESTROYED, THE
WOMEN HE DESTROYED, HE HAS
APOLOGIZED TO ME, HE HAS NOT
APOLOGIZED TO PAULA, HE
APOLOGIZED TO JUANITA, BUT THERE
WAS A PURPOSE FOR THAT.
AND HE HASN'T APOLOGIZED TO
LESLIE OR NUMEROUS OTHER WOMEN
WHO HAVE COME FORWARD AND SAY
THEY TOLD STORIES ABOUT HIM.
HE NEVER WILL.
HE DOESN'T GET IT.
JUST THE WAY IT IS.
>> Laura: HE SEEMS TO THINK --
HE HANDLED IT WELL.
TO WATCH THAT INTERVIEW, HE
DIDN'T SAY HE WOULD'VE DONE
ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY.
EVERYBODY MAKES MISTAKES IN
THEIR LIFE.
COULD HAVE, SHOULD HAVE, WOULD
HAVE.
LORD KNOWS WE ALL DO.
BUT 20 YEARS LATER TO SAY, YOU
KNOW, I WISH I COULD TURN BACK
THE CLOCK AND, YOU KNOW, SHOW
BETTER JUDGMENT.
BUT, I MEAN -- I DO THAT 50
TIMES A DAY.
"WHY DID I DO THAT" -- IT'S A
LITTLE STRANGE.
ON CNN, OFFERED SOMEWHAT TEPID
CRITIQUE OF THIS PERFORMANCE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THERE COULD HAVE BEEN A MORE
PRACTICE ANSWER, OR ONE, I WOULD
THINK, ALLUDED TO THE NOTION
THAT THERE WAS A CHANGE IN THE
PAST 20 YEARS.
OBVIOUSLY, THE RULES WERE
DIFFERENT AND HE WOULD'VE DONE
SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY TODAY OR
HE WOULD SAY SOMETHING
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT IT TODAY.
>> Laura: HE COULD HAVE HAD A
MORE PRACTICE ANSWER.
JUANITA.
>> MY GOD...
BE WHEN HE COULD'VE ALSO NOT
PORTRAYED HIMSELF AS A VICTIM.
HOW DOES HE BECOME THE VICTIM IN
ALL OF THIS?
>> I KNOW!
I KNOW.
I SAW THIS DECREPIT, ANGRY OLD
MAN WHO WAS TRYING TO PLAY THE
VICTIM CARD.
THE SAME MAN WHO 40 YEARS AGO
RAPED ME.
IT WAS DISGUSTING.
>> Laura: KATHLEEN, IT
WOULD'VE BEEN REALLY AMAZING --
I AM SHOCKED THAT MELVIN ASKED
THESE QUESTIONS.
>> I AM TOO.
>> Laura: IT WOULD'VE BEEN
REALLY AMAZING IF HE ASKED ABOUT
WANITA, YOU, THE OTHERS, BUT HE
FOCUSED ON MONICA WILENSKY
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE IMPEACHMENT
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE IMPEACHMEN.
EVEN JOE LOCKHART -- LET'S PLAY
THIS QUICKLY.
JOE LOCKHART, FORMER WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SAID THAT
YESTERDAY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HIGHLIGHTS THE VAST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WAS IT
LIKE 20 YEARS AGO OR TODAY.
IN THE INTERVIEW, HE SUCCUMBED
TO BEING THE VICTIM AND FEELING
VICTIMIZED.
>> Laura: VICTIMIZED, KATHLEEN
KATHLEEN.
>> HE LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE
$16 MILLION IN DEBT?
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT BEING IN
DEBT IS LIGHT AND NOT BEING ABLE
TO GET A MEANINGFUL JOB AFTER
BEING THROUGH ALL OF THAT.
HE HIRED ALL THESE WOMEN WHO
WORKED IN HIS OFFICE AND HAS A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY.
HE HAD A LOT OF WOMEN AROUND SO
HE COULD, YOU KNOW, ASSAULT THEM
HE COULD, YOU KNOW, ASSAULT THE
THEM.
THERE IS NO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
POLICY IN ARKANSAS.
THERE NEVER WAS ONE.
>> Laura: KATHLEEN, IF HE HAD
CALLED YOU TODAY AND SAID, LOOK,
I KNOW IT CAME UP BAD IN THE
INTERVIEW, BUT I'M REALLY SORRY
FOR CAUSING YOU PAIN, SORRY FOR
WHAT I DID, WOULD YOU ACCEPT HIS
APOLOGY?
>> NO.
I TELL THEM THE SAME THING THAT
JUANITA TOLD HIM.
>> Laura: WHICH WOULD BE...
>> I WOULD TELL HIM TO GO TO
HELL.
>> Laura: JUANITA, SAME
QUESTION.
EVERYBODY CAN BE REDEEMED,
RIGHT?
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE IN
REDEMPTION, ALL OF US.
MOST OF US DO.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE -- I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANY REDEMPTION
IN REGARD TO BILL AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
I WOULD PROBABLY TELL HIM THE
SAME THING AGAIN TODAY.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.